one goes down there's a shutdown
the fights coming through another kill
comes through actually for Jen to pick
that one
let's check the numbers of Alchemist
already been a double kill in for
Jensen's midlaner here odds are now
stuck in a bit of a math equation to be
2 over all right and if the typical
academic route Jensen we used to go down
Watts a bit more wildturtle running for
dear life Chico comes through into the
trade in a three for one so far
Wow done a complete control him they're
trying to get back into it Gerson Jensen
bridge beer could exhaust rain events
gonna kill Pacific there's the kick here
comes through the here comes just over
the blast shown as well and they're
gonna land us on a Cheryl's gonna land
Jensen locked out for four seconds or
more we're gonna try to help but it's
gonna come in in time exhaustion Hunter
closed them down the damn it is their
chance against the kill grid for a bit
their impact of course very tanky arrows
gonna hit Jensen now as Empress we're
going to keep them alive well he's gonna
tag on the floor go the T offense of the
agenda Redemption now clean deep right
there from behind the 200 is all but
secured this one a little bit faster
than previous and a little bit just a
bit more one side of the game one here
cloud9
this time up the backs of contract with
the insane early game on Lee sin to zero
over TSM not just yet Jensen Watson get
the shield ouster run for dear life has
the ulti still up will he go for the
killing of key spots where the double
kill he was right there on top but
they'd forgotten existed and now
finally the trigger map control Jetson
with the patient's on his chronobreak
right there these fights with the Boyd
leagues and the solder plants gets so
noisy people just can't track the shadow
and Jensen lands a massive game-changing
double kill c9 now ahead I gotta give
props to Jensen for his lip push and
being super good he was definitely
pivotal in that teamfight all the damage
he got in there and then we do have a
replay of that Jensen pushes up actually
without vision control but he knows he
has the Shen package comes in
immediately Chennault him so he's way up
with him - it's Daniel days in his
parallel convergence get this done so he
has that massive high AP ratio on the
shield but then as Ray's [ __ ] here he's
got the GA so they know he could
potentially last a little while and this
is where the fight gets against has been
so good about this in teamfights always
landing in his parallel convergence cord
the shield and then keep and chase
surges kind of stick around but with
this our altar and everything you can
hardly see where he's gonna fly back to
gets the double kill that's when it
decides to turn Vlad gets hit by his
first - hero Joe says doesn't matter
because they close in
look at that chunk committee they're
gonna find this down in the contract so
they've been it's muffin time no they
can't deal with the Terrance terms of
invulnerable and that's one kill picked
off some days for his chaser is going to
be next the Koreans are probably in
cloud nine foot coverage ensign that's
of all deadlines the last one standing
he's not even that anymore uh triple
kill for Jensen in cloud nine will
cement themselves in that first place
tie they will be two and zero that's
going to be the game the match in cloud
nine and AG week won first place with
their former teammates of black West and
such good team fighting by c9 down the
stretch right there Jensen deathless
that game Jensen has been on point his
echo in Game one as well as his series
against bjergsen on Friday
I expected us to be a pretty good team
as time progressed but it definitely
came as a surprise to me to survey
Jensen who was one or two in the mid
lane last summer or last year in its
entirety comes in and still shows up
very heavy burst in the middle that was
some way to go we move back in now
buttons out of the way the context
changes in bungalows almost an office
tonic trying to change the damn Jensen
thanks however there's a kill but Donna
Jensen now cutting away invisible
without always trying to take him down
but Jensen does every spot it doesn't
even need it as contracts gets that kill
and immortals committed everything with
that soda not acquit back in as well
after the late trips then go and go like
a scribe Guinea it's over by impact back
to be three kills as Atlantis just out
of reach yeah Jensen does some damage I
think it's safe to say with that build
at this stage in the game Claud and I
would spot
clean-looking first game will shoot down
the Nexus and improve that record this
team is looking absolutely red-hot
Jensen in particular eight one and four
held that for TCS advantage all the way
from ten minutes till the end of the
game
I mean credit to Jensen he's an
incredible player he's a particularly
good Lane and when he's allowed to play
the stuff he wants to play but that's
known information how many more can they
get darshan is out of HP slow flow comes
in Genesis back into the mix there's his
third kill the game and seized item
choices as well where darshan goes forth
a banshees fail and they're just trying
to get tanky on the side of clgs by the
Walmart waiting side contracts has to be
careful here it is a bench though out of
contracts Lyra first it is going to be
contracts down and then they drop leer
the fight still going on
Apollo over the wall I don't think you
want to get that close he actually
nobody get to the team and get himself
go side and Jensen's out of this one we
got healed now coming from sneaky Jaco
standoff deadly flourish they fit
another one
Seraph comes through on a late late
teleport both of the top laner said all
right this is going for the long haul we
have to engage arcane smash Sarah gets
dropped team has to make a play on the
other side contracts going hard spirit
refuges and so he buys himself some more
time Jensen warping in out of nowhere
ninja cow right in the front line about
ninja might be able to
so he tries to go into the exhaust it's
almost getting him to close and giving
himself to parents us all sense of
security
one two three four and Cinco and then
sneaky opens up and Jensen is just
running them down now impact got it with
the ultimate on he doesn't care about
turrets able to pick everybody up there
could be able to sideswipe the rest of
the team here follows too low to
participate no be a big one from Jensen
very nicely aimed around the corner is
able to drop Apollo get out of the
curtain call tries to get the shock wave
in it looks like they're gonna get drop
in the top ten jet there goes Haku Oh
Jensen with that damage six zero go on
the base entry but they do find the win
they do find the 2-0 cloud9
take me down Italy Wow tonight still
undefeated the team to beat in the NA
LCS be done right off the bat though
flashes down they are making the rinse
and repeat gank a few more is he at the
root that's gonna be one more hit don't
do that contracts box his auto-attacks
though Jensen get the kill very
well-played oh that syndra closing the
game
Jensen walks over the hill for himself
things that shouldn't happen on the rift
oh here comes a Katie and though they
want Jensen this is great play from jets
enemy dodges a pretty much every
curtaincall shot and then looper misses
his hook in that could have been an easy
kill for them if they were able to have
that skill shot accuracy but they do not
land the hits on Jensen he dodges the
mouth it's going to be a win for cloud 9
they're gonna come up with another 200
and cloud 9 moves to 6 and 0 in the NA
LCS still perfect looking great this
season is foul 9 seen on have gone
against the best and meet with them all
and Jensen has always been a top
performer for the team when he does get
ahead I definitely think this is the
real winner hopefully